F
SO A TEEACHS DEMAN
LLIO OF DOLLARSO R THESCOL,  NE2
ORDER T OPE A CRTER SCHOOLRESOUN
FOROUNG BCK MENN ATLTA.
NGANDA ISHE FOUND OF
THE FOY
U HE SN HIM BEFE.
COUNY AND W I INSPID Y HPENE ACT
TOO WH YOU A DOI RHTNO WHI ISAKR
TH GOVNMEN TRIED T SHU YOU
YOUAD THE SERINNDEN DN
EREN ATLANTA TT TRIESO
GET HISRONIES TO STOUDO.
BUT NOYOUAVE T POWEROO
RECT T THEIDS, HAVE THE
PANT GOIRECY TO TIDS,
LK AUTT.OU SOOL.
LAWRENCEI HA BEE WKING
SEEIHEMOTE AE TOABLE READ,
IAS WONDERIOW AND WTHE KS WE BNE
AND MIDDL SCHL, E CETA. SOOL
ESE DS C'T RD A WRI.
IEANITERLY JUST THA
M WDERI WHY TSE KID
N'TEAD A WTE ANDOING
TO LOOK AT T STATISTSIGHT
NOW ONLY9%F OIGH SCHL
MATH WHENHEYRAE.CIT I
DER0%F TSEHILDN
PRICIE IN RDI.
THEY A TOUNG OH WEAVEHE
THES CLDRE AREEINGTE A
ILLIRATE
TH ARE GRAATINUNCTNALL
ON THING IANTO S SO MY
US TTOVEO S THA THE
ACHE D'T WT T TCH, ET
TERA
IT NOTVEN THAT'S TT
THESEEACHS AANDCFEDO
IS SEYSTEM.
ACHE AO NEE SCHL
CHOI, T.
NOBO STASP F TEACHSWHHEY ND WEL.
THESE TCHER DON FEE SAFE
SCHL.
METIS JTIKES A OER
CHILENON'T
IUSTEARDOE BIDEN SAYHAT
THES KIDS ARE SLL SMONG A
HOOLTHE KS A HINGEX AT
SCHO.
ESEIDS ARE DOING CRA
THGS AT SCHOO
THES TEAERS ARE BEI
VIOLENY ASSLTED ATCHL,
ETETER
THESTORION'T HIT T
NE.
THES STOES DON'TOMEANHEREAN TIMS
IT GS INDICENTND ALL OVE
TH NEW
BODYTANDS U F TCHERTH IS WHY SOA
SCHOSIKEURS IS IMPTANT.
WE HE T GIV TEACHER AN
TION
RENTS A HING TROUBNG,TS  OPTN.
FOR THEI CHIREN.OOLING
THEYRE EECTI THE SOOLO
BEEACHG THEIR CLDRE TO
AD, TOE TEACHG THE
THE KS ARE4 AND 1 YEA
D A T PAREN DISCOVE
THATHEYAN'TEAD.
HAV SUC A TIC
LATISHIP WIT THE STEMSIN O CMUN.
WEL AOWUR PASRSND
CEAIN POLICIA INUR
COUNITY T UPITH STREGIC
YS F U TOONTIE B
GOVEMENTOR EVERYING ELSE.
THAT SE INGUITYOEACHUR
OPLE H TOO SOMHINGOR
OURSELS.
SOMETIS WAVTO P
PERI WRE WE AAYSDD IN A
DOEST HAPN WHENHE KIDW
WRITO U TYAN'T READ A
SOBODYASSED TM TOUGH
>> IS AYSTE HPEN?
IAVE TCHS EMAE ALLHE
I WI I COUUT THE EILS UPANLET EU
SO OFHE TEACHS I MY LAL
SCHOOLYSTE WIL CONTA ME
THUGH SCHL.S T KSG U
THEY AITERLYELLING THE
THEIDS CAN'TEADRRITETH ARE WONRE
E OFHE HIGST CMEATES
IN T STA.
PERP GGN ALBY, GRGIA
AIST O 30 YOU MEN, FM
AG 12O 2 226.
CETERA,HEYLL GOTNDICTED
FOR BNG IN THI GANI TNK TY MAY E
REONSIBLE R KLING A
9-AR-OLD I OUR CITY.
BU THE KS CAN'TEADND
ITE.
I TNK IHEY WER AT THEACAL SOOL G
TRADES A HOWO B AAN ANDASURCHL L
HOWOIE A TIE AND TKOPELE, E CETT
ITHESREAS
TH WOULDN'E LIN THE
LIS ABOUT TO GOOAIL A
ROWI THEIR LESWAY A
JU 12 ARLD,3 YRS OLD
YOU EECTI AID THAT C'T
READND WTEN A CY WITHO
BE SE TYP OF AREERSOND
ANDHESEEACHS WHO A.
YING THEEARDT TO TEA
DIERENY B THEY A BEI
WELL.UED B THE SYSTEMS
HAVE T G OUT OF TT TIC
AND CATEYSTE OF OUR OWN
>> Lrenc O ROA LEA TO
DOVERENT.
BA.HE GOTO TE T PERWEAVEOT T ST.